istiklal grand mosque in Jakarta drew
hundreds of worshippers on Wednesday
evening ahead of the start of the
fasting month of Ramadan there were
similar scenes at Kuala Lumpur's article
mosque Muslims say the annual fasting
ritual is designed to cleanse the spirit
as well as the body so Ramadan is like a
once-a-year boot camp a process for you
two to get back on track or for you to
find yourself or to deepen your
knowledge so if we inshaallah for you to
find here inner peace within fasting is
also intended to remind the faithful of
the suffering of those less fortunate
this year that might include the
inhabitants of damascus markets here
maybe well stocked but the Syrian
conflict has increased poverty and
raised prices leaving many families
struggling to afford basic necessities
oh my gosh I mean we're fasting even
without Ramadan we have only one meal
per day we see apricots that cost three
to four hundred Syrian lira the same
goes for cherries oranges and
watermelons we take pictures of the
fruit and look at them on our mobiles
despite the difficulties most people
will try their best to heed tradition
Muslims around the world will break each
days fast with water and dates at sunset
before gathering for a family meal and
offering prayers in the mosque